[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et si cette réalité n'était qu'une
illusion
très tôt enfant je spécule est déjà
beaucoup
je me souviens d'une chose en
particulier c'est ce rêve que je faisais
dans lequel je me lever de mon lit pour
aller décrocher la carte du monde du mur
de ma chambre et découvrir qu'il y avait
au dos un autre monde
cartographier
un enfant passionné par le mystère le
secret la chasse aux trésors et plus
particulièrement par tout ce qui est de
l'ordre du souterrain des trappes des
passages secrets des chemins de traverse
un enfant intimement persuadés qu'il
existe autre chose que cette réalité là
le vôtre celle ci est que ce sentiment
fascine obsède et ne quittera jamais
alors je comprendrais beaucoup plus tard
mais c'est de cette manière là que se
manifeste chez l'enfant
ce que nous adultes nous nommons
l'attrait pour ce que nous adultes vous
nommant spiritualité
vers l'âge de 8 ans je m'étais mail
m'imaginer que cette réalité là était
comme une pièce quatre murs sans fenêtre
et que nous ne faisions finalement que
des core i7 pièce déplace un meuble on
arrache la moquette on change la
tapisserie est exactement comme nous
changions de partenaire de métier de
lieux de vie
et vous il arrive parfois quand
déplaçant un meuble on trouve une trappe
qui mène justement vers un autre monde
imaginez la surprise de cette personne
qui ne connaît que sa pièce toujours
parker qui n'a vécu que dedans dans
cette réalité et qui en changeant de
moquette trouve un passage secret en
2001 je suis étudiant et mon seul argent
de poche
ma seule source de revenus provient du
billard que je pratique en compétition
mais seuls revenus dépend donc de mes
résultats sportifs et par la force des
choses je me qualifie cette année là
pour mon premier championnat d'europe
les trois années qui ont suivi le verrez
ça fonctionne beaucoup par trois chez
moi les trois années qui ont suivi je me
je remporte trois titres de champion de
france je me qualifie pour trois
championnats d'europe les trois
championnats du monde où je loupe trois
fois le podium
le podium de peu en trame de fond de
cette période ma fascination pour la
spiritualité
le mystère est omniprésente et je tente
de satisfaire sa à travers des lectures
sur la religion la psychologie la
spiritualité beaucoup beaucoup de
spéculations en somme quand très vite je
me retrouve confronté à un plafond de
verre
je me mets à avoir des vertiges à chaque
coup que je manque au bia est pire à
chaque défaite
ce plafond de verre entrave la
progression et me fait même régressé et
logiquement je me mets à préparer ma
sortie
et évidemment je décide de faire
facteur pourquoi facteurs parce que dans
mon esprit d'étudiants c'est génial on
se lève aux aurores on fait du vélo
jusqu'au milieu de l'après midi puis sa
mort a laissé beaucoup de temps pour me
consacrer à ce feu intérieur à cette
vérité qui brûle en moi depuis toujours
la spiritualité
alors j'en vois mon cv à la poste et je
me rends à l'entretien d'embauché
les recruteurs et moi on se rend
rapidement compte qu'il ya une erreur
mon cv ayant atterri sur la pile des
candidats aux postes de conseillers
financiers
ah mais moi je veux pas faire banquier
je veux faire facteurs mais si mais si
vous verrez banquiers c'est très bien il
ya quatre mois de formation et en plus
vous avez le goût de la performance
il me voilà donc conseiller financier et
le jeune homme qui a battu e qui a bâti
toute sa ré toute son identité illusoire
et sa valeur sur des titres et des
résultats sportifs décide de mettre un
terme à la pratique du billard cette
pratique qui m'aurait occupé jusqu'à
parfois huit heures par jour pendant
plus de dix ans et qui m'aura par
conséquent privé d'une
grande partie des relations sociales
normales que sont celles d'un adolescent
et pour lesquelles je n'étais d'ailleurs
pas doués du tout mais la valeur de
substitution étaient là sous mes yeux de
banquiers l'argent et je me suis mis
très logiquement a développé le même
acharnement et la même obsession et la
même persévérance dans l'accumulation de
cette nouvelle valeur que ce que j'ai
appris à le faire pendant mes dix ans de
pratique sportive
par la force des choses je trois ans
plus tard je suis débauché par une
grande banque française pour faire
gestionnaires de patrimoine et trois ans
plus tard je deviens gestionnaire de
fortune pour une banque privée
les montants qui me sont alors confiés
sont de plus en plus important
ma rémunération suit cette logique et si
bien qu'à cette époque je m'étais mis à
acheter un ou deux immeubles par an ce
qui contribue bien sûr à me tenir encore
plus loin de ma vérité intérieure
quand
trois ans plus tard je me retrouve dans
une situation de harcèlement moral
je fais un burn-out on parle de
licenciement je fonds en larmes et je me
dis ça y est c'est le moment maintenant
je vais tirer un trait sur cette
carrière qui me correspond en rien du
tout ça fait un peu plus de dix ans et
je vais pouvoir enfin m'a donné et
plonger dans ce qui m'anime depuis
toujours dans cette vérité intérieure
je rentre chez moi en pleurs et j'ouvre
ma boite mail et par un curieux hasard
j'avais reçu un mail le matin même d'un
recruteur qui me demandent si je suis
intéressé de travailler pour la plus
grande banque du monde
ce à quoi je réponds oui si on double
mon salaire ce qui l'abcès ceux qui
l'acceptent après le premier entretien
et me voilà réengager dans la poursuite
extérieur de ces choses qui ne peuvent
être comblés que de l'intérieur
trois ans plus
cet employeur dans une tourmente
juridique particulièrement médiatisé
procède à une vague de licenciements
dont je fais partie je rentre chez moi
en pleurs j'ouvre ma boîte mail
pas de mail mais par un curieux hasard
mon téléphone sonne une heure plus tard
et c'est un recruteur au fort accent
suisse qui me demandent si je suis
intéressé par l'idée de rejoindre une
des plus grandes banques de suisse au
poste de vice président j'accepte et la
course
tinue travailler plus pour gagner plus
toujours plus loin de soi
la suite vous la connaissez
trois ans plus
art le licenciement économique est au
rendez vous et c'est là que je prends la
meilleure décision de ma vie ne pas
ouvrir ma boîte mail est un bon
téléphone et prendre une année
sabbatique décidé de
rose et âme dans cette vérité intérieure
qui m'anime depuis enfants alors
pourquoi est-ce que je prends cette
décision à ce moment là et pas trois ans
plus tôt ou trois ans plus tard pas
déconner non plus pourquoi je la prends
à ce moment là peut tout simplement
parce que quelques jours auparavant
avant l'annoncé de ce licenciement
économique quelques jours peut-être
trois joseba je suis convié à une soirée
mondaine comme il y en a beaucoup dans
ce métier là où c'est ce genre de soirée
où il est de bon ton de deux d'étaler sa
réussite avec une coupe de champagne à
la main et une cravate de luxe et pas ce
fait ces sites cravate avec les haches
dessus comme dans comme dans roue
secours et et beaucoup de monde à la
soirée mais je me rends compte qu'à pas
grand monde avec qui je vais pouvoir
partager ma quête existentielle ma quête
spirituelle et mes considérations
spirituelles sauf peut-être ce jeune
homme là bas assis sur un canal ne
cherchez pas y'a pas de canapé
assis sur un canapé à l'écart de la fête
timide et donc je vais le voir et je lui
demande s'il s'ennuie autant que moi il
mérite qu'on en parle pas je rentre
aujourd'hui même d'amazonie où j'ai
passé trois mois avec des chamans à
boire de l'ayahuasca sec sa confidence
éveille la curiosité au plus haut point
et on a discuté quatre heures ce soir là
sans champagne alors je ne sais pas si
vous connaissez ou si vous avez déjà
entendu parler de l'ayahuasca mais c'est
un breuvage qui est composé de deux
plantes amazoniennes dans lequel se
trouve une molécule qu'on appelle des mt
cette molécule est produite par notre
cerveau à l'état naturel
naturellement et des études sont en
train de montrer qu'elle est également
sécrétée par nos poumons en fonction
deux exercices respiratoires
et cette molécule est produite par notre
cerveau lors de nos rêves et au moment
de la mort et c'est ici que je me dois
de faire une petite ellipses juridique
puisque cette molécule est ce breuvage
bien que la molécule soit bien sûr
naturel est interdite à la consommation
dans quelques pays dont la france
on en arrive à interdire des choses qui
sont tout à fait naturel dans notre
corps donc on est tous en état
d'illégalité cependant ce breuvage est
inscrit au patrimoine naturel et au
patrimoine historique et culturel du
pérou et je ne jeûne incite donc
absolument pas à sa consommation
je ne fais que
j'ai mon expérience de l'autre monde et
de l'autre dimension à laquelle il donne
accès cet autre monde c'est autre
dimension
les tribus amazoniennes ils ont accès
depuis plus de 3000 ans et décrivent ce
monde comme beaucoup plus réelle que le
nôtre certains disent un monde plus
grands comme j'avais rien d'autre à
faire pendant mon année sabbatique
je suis donc allé au contact de ce que
j'appelle l'expérience directe
l'expérience directe c'est quoi c'est
passé du savoir qu'on accumule comme je
lé fais depuis l'époque 30 ans à travers
les livres passer du savoir à la
connaissance c'est à dire passer de la
spéculation et d'intellectualisation au
vécu de l'expérience directe passer du
savoir la connaissance c'est comme
passer du dogme religieux à la
spiritualité
c'est à dire passer de la croyance ou
l'adhésion en l'expérience d'un autre à
la création de sa propre expérience je
prends donc un billet d'avion pour
l'amazonie à la rencontre de ce que les
tribus là-bas appelle la médecine dans
la jungle
une heure après avoir bu ce liquide
noire et épais j'ai accès à une
certitude c'est que non
tirez jamais vivant
la peur viscérale qui me traverse et la
même peur sans doute que les peuples
premiers ont rencontré lors de la
première éclipse
voilà j'ai 34 ans c'est terminé fermez
les rideaux ça s'arrête là alors je suis
là bien sûr mais je vais pas vous
raconter en détail les nombreuses
expériences que j'ai traversés avec les
plantes maîtresse dans la jungle je vais
juste vous en livrer la synthèse ma
synthèse une expérience spirituelle qui
mène à la mort de lego à la dissolution
de l'illusion de l'identité et de
l'illusion de cette réalité et
l'illusion de la réalité
les bouddhistes ça fait 2500 ans qui
s'empare long sur la nature illusoire de
cette réalité là une expérience
spirituelle qui nous permet d'entrer en
contact avec
nos intelligences universel une
conscience universelle qui peuplent tout
le vivant et dont nous faisons partie
avec laquelle nous pouvons interagir et
qui nous donne accès à
monde dont l'origine un monde dont
l'existence est débattu depuis que
l'homme est en mesure de parler cet
expert
en cela les traditions lui en donner
beaucoup de noms depuis des milliers
d'années
l'éveil spirituel samadi dans
l'hindouisme satory dans le zen après
trois semaines de
de diète dans la jungle avec les plantes
maîtresse je rentre en france
pour me mettre à écrire j'ai décidé donc
de rendre compte de ces enseignements
des enseignements comment apporter ses
expériences aux frontières de la mort
j'ai commencé à le faire bêtement de
manière anonyme d'abord sur une page
facebook que j'ai nommé par un curieux
hasard
le nombre d'abonnés s'est emballée pour
atteindre aujourd'hui les 30000 de cette
page facebook sont nés trois livres une
vocation de thérapeutes thérapeute c'est
quelqu'un qui prend soin
étymologiquement et l'organisation de
stages au cours desquelles j'ai souhaité
ouvrir un espace de transformation et de
guérison par la parole et l'écrit
voilà quatre ans que j'ai décidé
d'enlever le masque que j'ai décidé de
vendre mais bien de faire le plus grand
voyage du monde
le plus grand voyage du monde il fait 50
cm
à partir de là
là
si vous ne l'avez pas déjà fait je vous
invite à en
reprendre l'examen de cette pièce que
notre réalité à la recherche de votre
trappe
celle qui mène vers ce qui brûle depuis
cette vérité qui brûle en vous depuis
toujours peut-être peut-être vers
l'exploration d'un autre monde quel que
soit votre moyen quel que soit votre
situation
je vous invite à entrevoir la
possibilité qu'ils existent et qu'ils
émanent de la nature et du vivant une
mystérieuse intelligence collective une
conscience universelle qui peuplent tout
le vivant et dont nous faisons partie
c'est la capacité à rentrer en contact
avec cette intelligence et la capacité à
garder un contact permanent qui est une
des définitions du mot spiritualité en
conclusion je vais vous livrer ma
conviction c'est que cet intérêt
c'est universel cette conscience
universelle qui émane de la nature et du
vivant favorise par de curieux hasard
les humains qui permettent son expansion
[Applaudissements]